all right and we are live the last word
with laura cognito ibotta's thai guy
travis fresh on that thursday evening
careful before we even start it feels
good to be back with my destiny brethren
welcome back i missed you guys i've been
working like a dog
but it's good to be back podcasting with
the crew got a special guest but before
we get into that e bontes how are we
doing sir like the shirt doing good uh
yeah you guys who like the advanced gg
world make sure you guys follow all of
us tomorrow got some hype coming your
way um
good times travis is just rolling his
eyes through the back of his head it's
all right someday i'll get hit yeah it's
like
it's like i'm good i don't need that
stuff uh no it's been a good week um
excited for what we're going to talk
about tonight and kind of getting
towards the end of the season
i got some nice news but the big thing
is i gotta check with our guy ty guy
travis because
he may he may be heartbroken because the
director of fast x bailed right after
week one how are you feeling travis
what's up
yeah it's a pretty rough week in the
fast and furious world but i mean the
good news is he still wrote the
screenplay and he's also still a
producer on it so
i don't know what the creative
differences could be if you wrote the
screenplay but i'm sure it'll be fine
fast and furious has had a lot of
different directors over the length of
its run um
and you know
fast and fade of the furious is one of
the better ones not redirected by justin
lin so as long as he's like writing it
and overseeing the series i don't it
doesn't scare me a whole lot i think a
lot of the fast and furious like news
that you see on the headlines are sort
of like overblown it's like people who
don't play destiny and then they read
like a destiny headline and they're like
oh my god crazy stuff's happening in
destiny but then those of us who are
actually in the community are like yeah
it's not that big of a deal that's how i
feel about fast and furious it's like
i'm so close to it i'm just sort of like
nah that's not even that big of a
headline like justin lin was off of the
fast and furious project for like years
and then came back and directed a whole
bunch of them and then was gone for a
while and then comes back so this isn't
even like the weirdest thing that's
happened
he's with that one director it goes in
the way that's high uh yeah yeah so this
is sort of just uh business as usual i
think but yeah we'll see how that ending
is it's been a fun week for
destiny star wars and fast and furious
so i'm i'm busy i got my plate full
nice
awesome a clunky
one of my buddies is in the star wars
experience like hotel where it's like 48
hours you do like the quest he actually
got to
he's doing that real life thing and
because his birthday is tomorrow so he
just was like he's like i know it's
expensive but i'm doing it so i'll be
curious to hear what that thing is like
because he took a couple pictures
already of what like the cafeteria is
like he's like it's a cruise ship but so
far on land room looks pretty crazy
though
nice yep it's cool
what about you
a lot going on fresh back from boston
big packs east trip uh last week with
the whole team
all the large impacts for the first time
which was which was cool we haven't done
all four of us in a long time since
probably like e3 you know had a couple
of writers with us from lordsgaming.net
so we were just covering all the new
games man all the new stuff it was a lot
of really cool exciting games in the
indie in the double a space
very excited about that and happened to
miss one of the largest swabs ever yeah
you did ever ever and
i know the largest swab ever
yeah you know how i feel about sandbox
changes so when i finally get back
finish all of the press stuff and the
emails and the coverage
like well what could have happened that
was so crazy and i'm like
yeah there's no sandboxes yeah
it's it's nuts so definitely definitely
i was looking at what you guys were
saying about that and then uh yeah i'm
just good to be back and start playing
destiny probably around
tuesday wednesday just gotta get my feet
wet again see what's going on and i'm
back man we got stuff to talk about and
we got a special guest we got to bring
in
yes so welcome to the last word episode
number 195
guardian games is upon us and maybe it
is the year of the floofers
but we will just have to see
as season of the risen is in the home
stretch and the temperatures are warming
up for the northern half of the world
the next season of destiny is one of the
few releases coming out this summer how
better to build hype for the franchise
than one of its biggest ambassadors in
the united kingdom sharing gaming with
his wife and son makes this guest's
journey a special one this family man
knows that hard work is the key to
success and he's putting in the overtime
for sure last time we had him on he was
a little shy of about two years ago and
since then he has rocketed up into the
youtube stratosphere with no signs of
slowing down whether it's knowing the
coming weeks what the coming week has to
offer with his monday guide or his
tuesday reset streams to kick off the
newest content spreading the latest info
sometimes even before it's released and
making sure we stay on top of everything
in this crazy universe of light and dark
i'm happy to welcome back a man who now
has over 133
000 subs on youtube over 25 million
views on his videos over 12 000
followers on twitch and about half of
that in his discord if you don't know
him you damn sure need to change that
let's welcome one of the hardest working
and nicest guys i am happy to see all
these levels of success for the one the
only charvinius or jarv how you doing
sir
lot of change in it since i was lost on
here wow like
i was nearly at six million channel
views i think when i was on here last
night
sort of come up i tear time flies when
you're having fun though right um that
two years has gone
well quick a lot's changed um
my personal life on youtube in destiny
obviously uh so yeah man
in the building good to have you back
brother i was talking to e while i was
like yo we haven't spoken to the job in
a while and i always like looking at
your timeline because one thing that you
do that i feel like a lot of content
creators don't do especially in destiny
or just in general doesn't have to be
destiny is you kind of
speak what you want into existence you
know i mean as far as your goals and
stuff like that you're like yo we hit
this milestone you always celebrate
another so salute to you man because i
love to see the journey the content is
fantastic when the little jar of eating
this video comes out like all right
let's see what he got to say what's
going on so yeah it's good to have you
back how you been otherwise which how's
how you feeling about destiny right now
i'm very curious
um i feel like destiny after the launch
of which queen anyway is definitely
probably in the best place destiny 2 is
in the best place it's been
i think probably ever at this point um
and a lot of the devs seem really hyped
about next season which is
exciting um
because i don't think i've seen him very
excited for a season i've seen him
excited for a major release but not a
season so
they've obviously got something up their
sleeves um but when haven't they so it's
going to be good
can be good but yeah celebrating success
is important i feel
if you're not going to celebrate it then
you can't expect anyone else to and um
it's really important to
doesn't matter how
you know big or small milestones need to
be uh celebrated because yeah they do
make the difference um they're
motivators right it's from one milestone
to the next and if you're not going to
separate it then
who is
the celebration and party of me
absolutely what you got for jobs since
he's returned yeah no i mean it's good
to have you back i wanted to ask you
um two things one did you give your um
play button to your son
uh it's currently up there because it
so basically i got it mounted in a frame
nice and um
it's basically like really strong tape
so what happened was
where his xbox is that tape was not
strong enough with the heat so
it came away so i had to get it reframed
and it's now basically hung in the frame
and it's currently just above the desk
out of the way
and so the plan is definitely for him to
have it back
i just want to put it somewhere warmer
we gotta make sure it's gonna stick
yeah exactly because i remember walking
in i'm like hang on a second that's like
mike is my head broken like that looks
weird like
like the straight the frame is straight
but the actual award wasn't and i was
like yo
i don't think he's done anything to it
and um and the guy who's local um
you say yeah just bring it back in and
he so he's actually hung it in the frame
now like proper
uh so it shouldn't go anywhere no and
see we'll see
nice
and then i wanted to ask because it's
definitely one of your huge ones every
week is
this week in destiny but you chose to do
that on a monday
instead of this week in destiny on
tuesday would we really start our weeks
and i wanted to see
kind of what was your thought process
behind trying to do it on a day before
is it just getting ahead of the game
trying to differentiate yourself what
was what was the idea behind that and
because it's been hugely successful
those numbers are massive
yeah i i would say that series in itself
has probably transformed the trajectory
of the channel i feel like the channel
was on a good trajectory anyway uh i
don't think we would have hit 100k as
soon as we did without it um
but it boiled down to i was having a
meeting with sort of my network and just
sort of like we're just coming up with
like conceptual ideas about
um something that is something something
that is unique to you in a way something
that people can associate to you because
like when you think of people like if i
think about i want a shotgun review i'll
just go and check out fallout he'll have
he'll let me know the barrel gives me a
range or not you know i mean like we'll
go there or if you want ray guys go
datto if you want news you go
go to my friend houndish he's there
pretty much on the daily hanging out
begging out news so i was like okay i
need some associate that can associate
with me and it was like we did the
streams on a tuesday
and then like we did the our sort of
pre-stream pre-reset piece
and people will be coming in chat and be
like asking about what's the night for
what's the weapon what's this what's
that we got a new mission what's the
season challenges
and i'll just be rolling it off be like
yeah it's this it's there you know so
i'm sat there and then in this meeting
with my network going well
on a tuesday before i stream
i know what's happening
because
i play i live it i live in the game so
like like people come in and i'm telling
them
it's like why are you not putting that
in the video though like is that
i don't know that's a good question
that's a good point that's a good
question
so
naturally like the question i get asked
a lot is where you get the information
from because people feel like i'm like
java soon and got like some secret like
it's just like some secret crystal ball
uh two truths too some inside knowledge
but um
you're not you'll know and a lot of
experienced players will know that
destiny and live games generally just
work on cadences and rotations so once
you work those out and how they're
displayed in game
then you're pretty safe
but anything's up for change because
apis can change bungie are
able to do that and there's some
incredible sources like gg today in
destiny
incredible sources um there's some
brilliant community members uh
caber she does some pretty amazing work
summarizing
all the raid stuff
those cadences challenges and all that
sort of stuff so there's there's loads
of resources out there but what a lot of
people don't do
bring that together yeah um so that's
what we do
and the idea between on doing it on the
monday as opposed to tuesday there's a
strategic element because everyone's
obviously
looking for reset on a tuesday
oh wow
i'm streaming on a tuesday and if you if
i started streaming after i posted the
video you know what happens yeah they
yeah exactly so i know we'll do it as a
this week thing because it's timeless
you can watch that video any day of the
week and it's relevant if you walk watch
a reset video on a tuesday
yes it's relevant for the week but
sometimes it's only positioned for that
day so i try and position it for that
week
um and eve even like towards the end of
last season we were doing like the lost
sectors for the entire week
you literally just cover everything for
the week
um so the idea but for that especially
like if you think of wellspring there's
specific weapons you need to get exotic
glaives it's like well what days of the
week are those though you know well you
need to plan to get on destiny wednesday
and thursday this week if you want those
two things it just helps people plan
their week a bit and that's sort of the
angle it's positioned it's less of a
reset
whilst the information is
based heavily on that i position it the
intention is to be a weekly like this is
what
is happening this week
and plan accordingly uh and that's
pretty much how that series sort of came
about really nice really really cool
really cool
trev any questions for the jarv
yeah you said um you think destiny is in
its
best place it's ever been
which i think probably some people on
this panel would agree with you on um
what
what would you give the witch queen
on a scale of one to ten if you had to
review it rank it um
and being you know a masterpiece work
one being uh something that could
scarcely be played and um
what do you think it could do to improve
where it's at right now oh oh
i'm gonna have to play this down then um
which queen say i think it's really
important to separate the campaign from
from everything i think from a
standalone
like a standpoint like the campaign is
heads and shoulders above everything
else that we've experienced from a
campaign perspective mission layout
objectives
no mission is just like
a 10-minute breeze it's like
let's lock out 40 minutes here we go you
know i mean and they are an absolute
pleasure to play and replay and i'm glad
they're weekly missions and
so from that standpoint i wouldn't ever
say like
i don't want to give anything a 10 out
of 10 because i feel like that's just
wait i mean you can really enjoy
something but ultimately there's always
room for improvement right so i think
bungie will probably agree that they're
always pushing
the perfection but you never really
achieve it right so i would say the
campaign is definitely up there with a
seven or eight in my eyes um
because i feel like it's it's a really
high bar
it'd be really interesting to see what
to do with lightfall and how they can
elevate that that's going to be the real
challenge uh pushing that
one the next step what about that what
about that rate
yeah
where you right there
oh man the raid yeah let's do it i
really enjoy the raid but there's
elements of it that i don't enjoy like
the final boss for me needs to have more
health like i'm too like we had a really
good we got a really good team for
master raid so we it's just a quick cap
on the raid
so master ray launched like i did my
daily my daily research stuff on the
research stream and we jump into the
rate probably about 20 to seven and
we're like okay we're going to do the
challenge as well first encounter it
shouldn't be too bad
we get a little bit stuck on the first
encounter because we're just learning
where champions are because we're like
well what's hard about this is it actual
combatants are difficult or is it just
they're just going to throw champions in
every corner and it was a
little bit of the first but more the
latter right so once we got past the
first encounter
it was it was
it didn't feel much different like it
was just like oh these are overloads
those are
those are on stops and stuff like that
right and then we two-faced roll call
master first
first try like on master
and it's like
and uh ivy who we ran with he he checked
our stats we weren't even bothered like
it was just like we just want to get
master done because we didn't know
how far do adepts go is it just the
encounter or is it every encounter right
prism's in charge is a cool reward but
if you're raiding i feel like those
aren't your
your priority i feel like most of the
time players are probably capped out on
those materials and those materials are
lost even if they're granted in a ray
chest
and
so
and
whilst i don't think they're bad rewards
i feel like they're back the caps on
them are bad and which gives them almost
no value for an end game um sort of
hardcore player because that type of
player is probably ma
master working or every exotic and just
filling up their vault with supplies so
it's always excess but
yeah we ca we finished like
381 in the world for master raid
we started 40 minutes late and did the
challenge
wow
but that that tells me like
master isn't what i would hope it to be
like okay i want master to be like
contest like i wanted to be actually
difficult
not just champions and i feel like
champions
are just
the easy answer to making something
difficult but not the right answer um
and they need changing as well they
they're a bit long in a tooth now
overloads are still inconsistent
uh unstops you stun them and i'll just
they'll be they've just spin towards you
now it's like wait
like beginning of the season i was like
yo look it pops up on the screen hear
the noise audio cues everything you
expect and this guy is literally just
like
coming to shoulder charge me now so what
is this
um
so
i like the raid but i feel like
they've
i feel like master vog is better than
master val personally
i know
some people might not agree with that
but i feel like time-lapse weapons are
definitely better than the depth of our
weapons for sure i thought that's a
misstep there so that i was like okay so
i gotta literally just queued it up too
well
i set it up no last week we it was me
travis and um we had live mondo on
um
and we got to talk into
talking about adept versus craftable
raid weapons
and i wanted to get both of the two
people here who's
we haven't heard your takes
where do you guys stand on the adaptory
weapons versus the craftable raid
weapons
i don't want to put words in anybody's
mouth so where do you guys stand on
those jarv you were like mid-sentence
but that's that's one piece that i
wanted to ask most of you about so we
may as well do it since we're in the
middle of it
cool yeah i don't mind picking picking
that up um to begin with
i honestly
other than cosmetically they don't
actually hold any value right there's no
correct role that you desire
both
perks in the column are random and
weapon crafting removes that randomness
so it's like
i'll just craft what i want and i'll
give it an enhanced perk if i really
want it but if it was going to be random
like that
i would have put enhanced perks as a
possible drop chance like
but also have a created role for them
too
because there needs to be a fallback and
because why wrong master like why
other than to do the challenges you're
one and done like that's pretty much my
view on it and that's unfortunate
because i actually really enjoy running
it i just don't have enough reasons to
run it other than just getting the seal
at this point which is a real
disappointment i like where they're done
with the like the ray ghost and hiding
it behind the puzzle cool putting the
sparrow behind some of the triumphs like
completing the master ray for example to
get sparrow
nice but it's just the dip the
implementation of a debt weapons and
what they are compared to like time lost
versions and what weapon crafting means
for those i just feel like
it could have been a bit more love
showing to those
cog what about you yeah i don't know if
you had a chance to dive into this
yeah job said it pretty much how i felt
you know you know i'm the big
proponent of of time investment and and
value for what what i'm getting so
that what we all discussed this even
prior coming in right we were like hey
how is this going to land
in a world where there's crafting right
what what is going to make
this an attractive option to run
consistently
and i think job's on it because like for
me it's one of those things when once we
found out what the rewards were
and it's it's the random nature on top
of that so you can still run it
and theoretically get a bad role or
undesirable role
and that to me defeats the purpose
because it's like again the the adept
aspect is not a sexy proposition to me
that is not you know something that i'm
even when during the grand master phase
like it wasn't anything for me that i'm
like okay i have to have this this is
such a definitive thing for example like
when we talked about
um the what was the the dungeon for the
uh the funny dungeon what the galahad
was in it crazy ever
right
you know
having at least having the extra armor
slot
is an attractive thing on some level
right that that okay you know what if
you really build craft you really want
to spec a build having an extra slot
there's value in that to me you know
they just they they don't they didn't
present it with basketball and that's
unfortunate because like trump said like
you do it you run it you get you know
your your challenge done and i think
they mean they may have to revisit it
because i don't think they could just
continue to do what they've been doing
now that crafted exists and travis is
shaking his head so let's go chef
i mean i already said my my view last a
week but my view is sort of opposite
your guys which i think that destiny
players who are super super hardcore
are
um
you know doing what they want which is
which is they want uh these
uh super high end activities to be
rewarding for them but
if they become if they're too rewarding
then they become mandatory for all
players that either
don't want to do that kind of activity
or don't want to grind for the perfect
role or
have a skill gap for it right and so
i i kind of see the beauty and the
current system which is you can get most
of the way to the god world that you
want it won't be as good of it as as an
adept that has all the right perks but
um you can get most of the way through
crafting which is a pretty high barrier
of entry but it's not unattainable for a
casual hardcore you know a hardcore who
isn't doing um master uh raids which i
i'm in that group like i play destiny a
ton and i would never do a master raid
just because i'm like yeah you know this
i did the main raid i don't need to do
it where everything kills me in two hits
um and uh
and
but the for the people who want to do it
for the people who are looking for
excuses to play destiny more there's
this marginally better
you know uh weapon type that they can
really grind out if they're trying to
squeeze every single like point out of
it so i kind of see beauty in that
system and i think if you make adept
weapons too much better uh then all of a
sudden it it makes the
casual hardcore want to throw their
hands in the air because they're like
well there's now i now to be competitive
i've got to play this other mode that
i'm really not interested in doing and
it sort of makes that stuff mandatory
rather than optional for the for the
sweatiest of the sweaty and that's how i
kind of see it now so
i just don't i don't want grinding and
dips to be to be mandatory because if it
is there's really no events i like to do
except for trials um you know what i
mean and it just it becomes too much of
a of a grind for those who
want to be competitive without having to
do it so i talked about this all last
week i'm just repeating myself now but
yeah yeah you guys aren't there for that
yeah the other depths are similar to
raiderdeps now when you think about it
right there's not really anything
different between them cosmetically
they're a little bit different
they're all random rolls
but it's how you obtain them right like
going to the lighthouse or getting a
flawless card or getting wins on even a
flawed
flawless next season will get you and a
chance another weapon but ultimately
it's still random right in terms of the
drop yeah the roles
so it's like i mean if that's their view
like yeah
trials is like the aspirational piece of
pvp content
that like like a top sentence of players
will engage with or be successful at but
it doesn't give them a weapon that's
completely like out of reach
they're too
average or above average players and i
guess what you're saying yes rav is i
think that's master vow right yeah yeah
it's not
it's not it might be out of reach for
some players but it doesn't mean that
you're
handicapped by not being able to obtain
it
correct i think that's i think that's
destiny's goal because if they make it
mandatory if they make it too good then
all of a sudden it's gonna just piss off
players that don't that aren't in that
you know top one percent of people who
are going to be doing masters because
didn't they say something like three
percent of destiny players do a rate or
complete array right it's like how what
what what must the percentage be for
master i mean i'm okay even though i'm
going to eat because i'm ready to burst
no no
i was trying i was the opposite of
travis last week so i went at it with
him
last week because
my idea was the idea that you have two
enhanced traits
on a craftable weapon you have a direct
path to a god roll if the meta shifts
then you can actually change your
crafted weapon to shift with the meta if
a perk gets nerfed then your gun is
still good as opposed to
pain in the light okay for some people
jarv is god tier so you don't count but
for a pain in the butt for a lot of
people
to go after a random role with the only
advantage being an adept weapon for the
adept mod versus two enhanced perks
which tend to give you traits like stat
boosts on some of those anyway
in my opinion the adept weapons have
absolutely zero value compared to a
crafted weapon because
you you can spend just as much time
going after both of them
one you're guaranteed to eventually get
a god rule one of them you have no
guarantee and theoretically it could be
made worse at any point
and it doesn't have access to enhanced
trade so my idea was
adept weapons suck
in comparison to crafted weapons
because they don't have the options that
craftables do so in my opinion
there's no artifice armor in the raid so
that's a missed opinion miss thing there
the raid armor doesn't have 11 energy so
you can't use the raid
mod for master which would be the idea
because that's where it actually could
have some benefit but then you can't
stick with your build
uh see i just thought master was doing
miss in my opinion shout out real quick
the gaming forte last word let's go uh
the background must have been cog's idea
actually it was mine uh i gave it to the
warlocks this week uh they also are due
to win this year so hopefully they do
for their sake so we can have an even
one uh have a great show gentlemen and
then also rook with the 10 super chat
with what looks like a hippo doing um
power slides in an office chair that is
an amazing sticker thank you um
my opinion was like the polar opposite
of travis's but i went through mine last
week so yeah that was me
the only thing i just add is just that i
understand travis point to an extent but
i think at the end of the day
the reason why
people don't engage in hard
activities is because you have to give
incentive and and you can't have
the i want to say crafting is the lower
end because it's not it is a time
investment it is it is it's a huge one
but those perks are better when you
throw enhanced perks into a pool and i i
think the happy medium that's probably
what jarv said which is kind of like
at least maybe one of those slots
has it and then adept yeah like that one
of the thing or what they used to do is
remember when they they give you the um
you know what was it when they started
doing the uh curated role the curated
role with the double option so it's like
okay you have more chances to get a
solid roll but if you run a
you run a a a master whatever
and and you end it and you get like i
don't know i'm just making up uh what's
the insidious
right yeah and you run around and you
get
you know i don't know what's two of the
worst perks and it's like you get two of
the worst perks in insidious after a
master
that is very demoralized
so it's just like yeah it's demoralizing
it's demoralizing to the people who were
gonna play destiny anyway okay so
looking to squeeze out that small
percentage because honestly i think you
guys accuse me all the time on the show
of being a pvp elitist and i think your
guys pve elitism is showing right now
because you're trying yeah absolutely
because you're saying like oh you know
the this this top percent it should just
it should grant us better perks that
just are just
elevate us above everybody else then you
put no carrot at the end of a stick in a
difficult activity and that point if
there's no incentive to play it as
opposed to look at my shiny triumph i
don't give a care about if the character
stick isn't there if there's no benefit
to running the difficult activity then i
find it difficult to do that i don't get
adept trials weapons because i'm not
that good but if i run a master raid
those should set themselves apart as
well
well adept trials weapons also aren't
good and uh that's fine you know what
they could do to make you guys
incentivized to play the activity is
they could make the activity fun
although that's a different discussion
yeah but but but why isn't that what
we're focused on because it's a loaded
shooter
all right yeah
the shooter
is here for the live this is why i had
that
run wow i'm
is to reward the player so you increase
the population base in said activity
which one is more important than a
looter shooter [ __ ] the loot or the game
being fun
both why can't you do both why can't
which one's true
you're trying to limit me in the box why
can't they do both why can't it be fun
okay okay okay how about this which it
is which it is how about this then you
choose
or activities that are fun those are
mutually exclusive
which one's more important in a looter
shooter
we don't need to separate this
but
it's fun
the problem that i have with all of
these conversations that i have with you
on every topic about it is that you're
like we're doing it for the loot like
it's a day job
what is the genre of the game
what is the genre of this game the genre
is lunar shooter but you're forgetting
the more important part like you're
forgetting the more important
you're okay so you're you're looking at
the genre i'm looking at the other part
of the sentence you said game
game it has to be the establishment
establishment
you can literally have a completely
separate discussion are adept weapons or
craftable weapons worthwhile is the
mechanics or champions that they put
into the master vow
well done to make the difficulty
worthwhile jarv literally just said he
rolled over it but also people are
really tired of champions which
overloads this season are probably the
worst
so are the mechanics in the raid not at
a fun state in master difficulty i think
a lot of us will agree on that one
yeah a separate topic so why don't you
fix that and see if it fixes the fair
bit but
the whole point is i literally just said
these are separate you can have loot and
incentive be separate from the mechanics
that you play
those are two different things to work
on that's all you guys are
my point is that you guys are
misdiagnosing the problem you're saying
oh well nobody's playing these
activities because they're not rewarding
no no nobody's playing them because they
suck they're bad that's why nobody plays
if the rewards wouldn't matter if the
reward was true if the reward was good
enough i bet you you guys don't know
anything about game design it's like why
why would l just listen to yourselves
why why should they if they make the
reward really good but the activity
isn't fun to play you're saying that the
reward should be so good that people are
forced to play a bad game mode no one's
saying that
no one's saying that the game should
suck you're saying you're you're making
it like this is it except
you're focusing on
which one's the bigger problem which
one's the bigger both of them at this
point
is just as important as the activity the
whole reason we're there being enjoyable
i like the normal version
and craftable goes with it
then you have something
the adept weapons
is worth it and master mechanics
that also feel not fun and just more
champion shoved in jar do you have like
a balancing take on this situation i'm
trying to play ref between these two i
need a third party i need a third party
i would say it's very important try and
try not tar everyone with the same brush
in this they are two different issues
but a key thing to think about
is trials has been bad
but when the loot's good people will
play it right and engagement right
it's just they call it engagement
that is terrible okay
travis
but that happens though and then the
feedback gets through and then since
then trials
has evolved it's continuing to evolve
next season with the depths being more
obtainable
through the through the you know for the
passage and stuff like that it's not
until that feedback gets to the studio
they can actually do anything about it
but they are two different issues but
fundamentally we've had the same issues
in pvp and you you'll know that playing
pvp primarily right of course and guess
what i guess what i hate about pvp i
hate when they do something like make
the rewards and trials good without
fixing the mode because then they're
just saying hey everybody play this
terrible game mode so that you can get
good loot and it feels like homework
when what they could do is just make the
game fun and then i would play it even
if the loot was just so so obviously i
want the loot to be good too but i'm
saying that's what i'm saying and that's
all i'm saying that's the first thing
you're saying thank god but here's the
thing though
here's the thing that's frustrating to
me is that people focus so much on the
loot like that's the real problem and i
take offense to that i'm just saying
that i didn't say that that's the thing
you you keep putting me hold on you keep
putting me in a box like i don't agree
that champions are bad at them exactly
we've all said that champions are not
great narratives separate discussions
it's not that it is
that you said it's a looter shooter it's
about you and i just disagree with that
no this is the first time you admitted
it that loot is important as well that's
all i'm saying that's not the first time
i've admitted it i'm just with me here
anyway we played the game even if the
loot was just okay if the game actually
was fun if the game mode of mastery we
agree
we agree yes we agree we have to fix the
champion
and we also agree the mechanics could
use some work
both are part of this equation and
that's i think
where we're gonna necromancer with the
10 super chat loot makes a looter
shooter but if game isn't fun story
isn't good or weapons don't feel good
most people leave other than just bad
loot so that's necromancer zeal's check
on it yeah yeah so i think that's my
point my whole point is i think that
the adepts could be
even if they're not that much better
than craftable weapons if they're a tiny
bit better people will play them as long
as they as the
underlying mode is fun and i think the
reason people aren't playing them is
because
you know the juice isn't worth the
squeeze because maybe they're a little
better if you get the right roll but the
actual mode is just
painful and nobody wants to do that
stuff for me
grandmaster nightfalls are painful if
they were fun activities i'd be like
yeah i'll get a little bit better for
that i don't need adepts to be crazy and
i think that the thing that players go
to first is they should make adepts way
better because if depths are way better
than people will play the game mode and
i'm like well maybe people shouldn't
play the game mode maybe we shouldn't
play it until it's actually an enjoyable
experience and that's my problem with
all these conversations as we started
talking about i didn't say that for the
record i know you didn't i
okay we're not gonna minimize that
that's all i'm saying you got you're
done travis
i mean i'm never done with this yeah i
know you're good
for the sake of job
yeah
anyway sorry about that
so yeah the campaign is probably an
eight i'd say the raid
is probably probably
a six or seven
i think i think
yeah i feel like
i don't think it's it doesn't feel long
enough like
i don't know
i don't know if that bungie's just got a
time in their head and they feel like
raids can only be a certain length and i
get they are massive development like in
time things and that's probably that's
part of the why we go
just quickly tapping on loot like
loot's an easy answer to something
that's
not performing as expected from an
activity standpoint because
you know they can just make put good
loot in there and people will play play
it until they
can adjust or fix it right it's it's a
temporary answer some of the times um
but not the the long-term answer i feel
like um
like what val does good is it takes like
perseverance and it sort of
slowly guides people that maybe haven't
accessed the ray before into the opening
section of that so it's not completely
alien to them i feel like that's a
fantastic way of actually opening that
gate a little bit more for new players
making it more accessible initially and
then the encounters are good
uh
hey man i feel like they're just getting
adding more symbols man like 25 this
time like i've learned a whole new
it's pretty pretty wild but um
i don't know if they're diverse enough
like compared to like encounters that
we've had before but i'm going through
i'm like oh it's this relic and it's
this mechanic
or but they're not new
um
so when it comes to like day ones and
working out what it is you do
well i know how this works
so
it's it's probably going down this route
and you sort of
you can anticipate more where this is
going from from like an entry standpoint
um
like the best thing out of the raid is
probably the last boss in my honest
opinion because he's something
completely new completely alien and we
fight in a completely different way to
anything we've thought in the game
before my only
um sort of critique is that he probably
doesn't have enough health for a final
boss um
but
i guess that's a bit of a i was like
felt like
two men two floored him on like master
but like no you know it's just
he's the best part of the raid
i like getting michael jackson kicked in
the face like it's awesome
um
but other than
that part of the raid i feel like the
rest of it whilst it looks incredible
like
i feel like mechanically it's too
samey is that
it sounds bad
let me ask you this no that's something
that is totally a fair statement let me
ask you this as
we are on year eight of destiny
is it our longevity with the franchise
at this point or is it their
lack of creativity or possibly lack of
what they can build into a
first person raid for example do you
feel like our experience with
seven different raids throughout the
years and one repeat but that many raids
throughout time
we are all we are starting to understand
what bungie seems to be capable of do
you think that's part of it
um
possibly i don't feel like it's like a
i mean they clearly have plenty of ideas
and we're clearly going to see things
that we never thought we'd see in
destiny later down the line and part of
it might be going back to the
accessibility standpoint if i know
exactly how something works it's a it's
a doddle for me to explain that to
someone else you know i mean you haven't
got to go back to the drawing board and
write an essay of a twab trying to
explain what something does or doesn't
do so like it from like
introducing new people into raids or
going through them through it like deep
stone deep stem was one of the best
raids to like teach people rates
but i don't feel like val is that
yet
um
i don't know why i don't like everyone
has clear roles but i feel like
they're not
as clear as like
deep like uh yeah deep stone like deep
stone is the best way to teach someone
you think it's more with the randomness
or or the sheer amount of of symbols or
a combination of both probably a
combination of it all like you've got to
try and like sometimes it's just say
what you see like like i did that with
last wish like i just saw fish swimming
through bacon it definitely wasn't bacon
but i just said say what you see mate i
don't i'll work it out
you'll figure it out no that's yeah i
mean we are at a point where i will say
those symbols where it's like four
different fish at least these are all
generally kind of their own thing even
if there are like 25 of my feeling games
yeah and they have names too which does
help granted there's 25 of them or
whatever it is which is
seven 27 sorry but there's a lot but
yeah they got away from four dragons
four fish four like there's not fish
blank it's one word and you know what it
is you can learn that one but also to a
point i will say
teaching people
again i haven't rated as much i rate it
a lot in this one so this one feels
comfortable to me but i also know
exhibition to teach
if you have more than say like two
people who don't know what they're do
it's like you go this side you go this
side you shoot stuff if there's more
than two people the idea of like trading
off and how you need to manage that
especially if you can't if you really
have to switch people in that's where it
gets messy and i think that much
symbols plus mechanics in one encounter
can definitely make teaching hard
so i fully get what you're saying there
because yeah like especially exhibition
is
when your team knows what to do it's
smooth but if you're with people who
don't know what to do it's chaos
yeah exactly like you get to caretake
you think oh this is just shiro chi but
he's just mega ugly like
you know
but obviously there's other elements to
it and then you get to like exhibition
it's like oh this is like running the
heart but it's before the boss now so
it's
it's
there's similarities there
and for most of the encounters though
everyone has a role that doesn't involve
them just standing there and shooting
stuff and even with exhibition
they have to move right and you have to
have an even split on the team they
still have a part to play
uh even if they don't pick up a relic so
it's it's good in that sense because
i've
we've all been in nfgs where people are
like yeah you know confluxes you just
stand there and just just shoot don't
die
yeah that's fun
like that's conflict is like to shoot
things
the shootings don't die and then jump up
on top of that rock when the legions
come yeah love it
that dude one time dude
get on that rock
vlog's getting the beat down too it's
fine
yeah but yeah so that's that's part of
why val for me
is is like a sort of a six or seven i
feel like if they
like improve to some they'll remove some
of the randomness i don't necessarily
think the loot is bad but i feel like
like have it like the like
briefly touching on the adepts like to
er to get them unlike vlog they're not
assigned to an encounter they're on a
knockout system so
if you're after submission it could take
you six weeks to even unlock it
um in your loot pool and then you can
buy a second one from the boss but it
still might be both trash but then
that's that's the problem that's the
problem with generally when it's rng
right
but
that in itself like it's another element
of randomness which frustrates but um
that's why i give it that um
i still think destiny is in its best
place
[Laughter]
so what's your overall score though
could you could you assign a score to
the witch screen that's the whole thing
was a package
now you got to take into like strikes
i would say
i would say it's a
a firm eight
and
a part that is the circums you have to
think of the circumstances that this uh
expansion was even produced in
the same as what i am right now in my
living room right
yeah completely remote the best campaign
we've ever seen they've introduced
weapon crafting
in its first iteration at least which
was something that we thought was never
getting destiny
at all because yeah destiny's always
been about r g up until this point
um
and then slowly but surely you know
3.0 on the subclasses so
it almost felt like we got a new
subclass even though we didn't like
i'm using void 3.0 in a completely
different way it feels new even though
it's not um
i think there's a lot of stuff that's in
destiny that which queen brought that we
sort of take for granted and those are a
few things that people don't talk enough
about i think add so much longevity and
value to the game long term
that are really going to underpin the
franchise you know in the next major
releases really i feel like it's really
just a really solid foundation to finish
this saga
and then carry over that foundation into
whatever the next chapter will be so
that's why i give it an overall sort of
eight because of the circumstances what
i actually don't done from a narrative
standpoint like through the campaign and
how that rail rolled out and
the super strong foundations it's
provided moving forward
cool
well i will say that is uh that's a nice
little intro there we got there so now
we've done our introduction
no it's that's basically the warm-up
right that's
yeah
uh no seriously though like that's one
of the reasons what's the point what's
the point of doing a show if we're all
going to agree exactly
sometimes i have to question if you're
just playing devil's advocate just to
get a rise no no no but i never thought
i love trav he
truly believes in what he believes
that's that's some of the questions
i believe and i don't care what other
people people say
after you're
because we know you don't care but yeah
that's that's really that's why we love
you uh also i scored it in eight for ign
so yeah so you guys dedication
dedication guys you got it yeah
uh shout out real quick i think
gaming410 we've got for super chat
travis is right i won't do certain
activities even if the loot is great fun
trump's all for me i refuse to grind
something that feels like a chore
trainer then you pro that was like
that's that could be the whole game
depending on where you define it so
careful i say my two favorite franchises
are star wars and star chores which is
destiny
[Applause]
well
um i think you missed another super chat
did you get dj's
oh oh where'd he go dj or you gotta get
mr khalid no perk is gonna make me any
better at this game you get what you get
hey bestie
shout out dj oros are you guys besties
now yeah we're destined i'm married
that's destiny besties your destiny
besties
is there anything from the major from
the sandbox i am excited for machine
guns massively
um is there anything else from the
sandbox massive 9000 word 12 from last
week that you guys wanted to shout out
or just like call to attention that you
read through and we're like damn that
sounds good or bad
anybody good job let job go because
yeah um same puff as you did machine
guns like xenophage going back to og
exactly and i polish that bad boy off
might even go back to war mine cells and
create some pretty explosive builds at
this point oh we got a job what their
seal bills are yeah
like it's i feel like it's long overdue
nice buff as well to machine guns um
did tweet today that they should
probably bring back super good advice i
feel like that would be pretty good
yeah that'd be pretty nice of a with a
40 buff um but yeah i feel like that'd
be good i don't know still be meta it's
hard to know because like
they angle certain weapons to be good at
certain things i feel like machine guns
are very much just that
good utility and clearing kind of weapon
and it isn't supposed to be something
that you just plow into a boss right so
it's like um
i feel like that could be good and
change change up a little bit maybe see
a little less linears next season
because of it yeah yeah yeah it depends
what the champion mods are going to be i
guess at that point always is yeah
we won't go down that rabbit hole what
about you about any uh any major shout
outs from the 12
yeah um couple of standouts um
leviathan's breath is going to be
serious um
very still don't know if that's going to
be enough for me to make me pick it up i
actually like it i'm one of the few that
use it and i i i like the potential of
it but the catalyst what they was doing
was just not enough so i want to see
what that does they went hard at it in
air accuracy they went hard
now it's about you're gonna spec
this thing
hard if you choose to really play that
way so you got that and shout out to
follow hear me laugh he was like i
watched one of his videos he's like yeah
for all you guys that say get head shots
let's see it now yeah yeah we're about
to get some skill checks we're gonna see
who how nice certain people are they
they say in pvp that oh i got a shot
because they really didn't affect you
know that the other stuff so you got
that machine guns like dropshipping oh
machine gun i really want to use a lot
of machine guns i was a little
disappointed that i don't feel they
touched 360s
i feel like 360 machine guns
they're getting a buff but i want to see
how they the the classes of the machine
guns differentiate themselves and i hope
that the law gets shot of the xenophage
i like that
and um
yeah and i i think that is in the
prediction or i'm going to ask you this
because i was going to um
are we predicting it's leaning
solar 3.0 next season most people tend
to think that's pretty much guaranteed
yeah okay yeah it feels like i would say
so yeah
i'm excited i think the the the
stability
and the uh the stability stat i think
was effective one of them affecting
flinch punch stability yeah now
stability on your guns and resilience on
your character both
i i like that because to me it now has a
defining role and if you want to play a
certain
style
i don't mind it so look let's see how it
lands though it sounds good on paper we
got to see how it lands but i was
excited also
i was going to say like when we did on
on tuesday stream when i was we were
talking about this and you touched on it
just briefly then
um
i speccing into stuff like
for me like for crucible i just always
put on what i deemed my best stuff or
the meta stuff right i'm not really
speccing into a way
or or
a build
yeah you play a certain way but it's not
build so like it's going to be
for one of our probably our first
opportunity to actually properly spec
into something like if you want to be a
fluffy warlock and flying around then
yeah speck into it you're just going to
need to hit your shots like
and that's going to be a first and
actually that's going to have it's going
to
hurt initially because yeah i guess a
lot of what we've had before just should
be like stompy's i think was a big uh
standpoint hold it closer
yeah yeah
so it's going to hurt but then if you
want to play that way then you you can
but you're just going to spec into it
and uh
and
build crafting and theorycrafting's
probably been
the best it's been up until this point i
feel i'm using elemental whales more
than ever at this point
i'm really expanding on what we do and
playing in different ways and i feel
like we're going to start seeing that a
bit more increasable which should be
interesting it could be frustrating at
points but that's probably going to be
uh part of like knocking the nails back
down in the wood when we do the uh 3.0
reworks right there's gonna be a few
standouts always but oh yeah of course
of course just a couple uh for me i was
just gonna say graviton lance at some
point i'm gonna have a reason to pull
out that gun so hopefully it's got some
potentials they were adding a little bit
more to the um
catalyst i think it was going to give it
a little bit more corporal turnabout got
rid of the hitting hand
yeah thank god the monarch got nerfed a
little bit i was happy and by lord of
walls it was a good run i don't know if
it's over but it don't look good for me
i thought i was going to slip through
another 12. yeah
they got me they got me i busted i got
locked up
so
um obviously yeah massive 12 last week
if you haven't read it and you want some
reading material for like seven trips to
the bathroom that'll take care of you
for a little while
but we've got guardian games officially
announced this week for obviously it's
been leaked already but officially
dropped it in the twab and
starts tuesday goes for three weeks
until the end of the season so actually
coming up on the last three weeks of the
season so the time is there actually
um just as before you're gonna be
earning medals you're aren't going to be
earning medallions for those medals and
you're going to be trading in your what
are they called combat cards why am i
thinking yeah platinum cards contender
cards and all those things just like
before it does sound like they're going
to get a lot of the activities raids
dungeons competitive
legendary sciops battlegrounds
lost sectors a lot of things are going
to be mixed in sounds like they're
involving a lot more
with regards to activities which is good
but i would say one of the first ones
strike scoring is back so i wanted to
get you guys take on strike scoring so
there's going to be two guardian games
playlists for strike scoring tuesday
wednesdays and thursdays your training
playlist kind of practice up see how
high you can get um for your entire fire
team friday saturday sunday monday
that's your time to get sweaty in the
competitive strike scoring play let's
get as high as you can get the rewards
you can um get all the buffs you're
going for so what do you guys think are
you excited to see strikeable scoring
back
what uh what do you guys think any
anybody gonna be looking for those
cheesy builds real fast
let the girls go through
what
i don't mind it i just wish it was here
all the time though um yeah i don't know
why it was taken out in the first place
but anyway uh it's a good addition it's
a good change
um
and it has its own benefits right you
hit certain thresholds you know like
torches in the tower
and cool little bonus boxes get sweet
little armor glows
because it depends how good the glows
are but then that's just the case of
you know it's just cosmetic and
temporary anyway and you're gonna have
to do that each week so it's no real big
deal i just wish there was like a
i wish there was more glows on a weekly
basis actually outside of events i mean
if i'm going to do a master raid or go
florist in trials like i mean
i mean
it's just just a cosmic it's cosmetics
weekly thing it would likely occur with
a little night
or another little halo
i think not strikes when it's good
there's a lot of cool medals in there
actually it's gonna change the way that
we play and it's gonna
people gonna be leading more into builds
much more now um just for laurels uh
because i still create those laurels to
get those contender cards um
so while some activities might be fast
medals
uh they might not be enough for you to
earn enough lures to buy a contender
card to get platinum or gold so
it's it's a it's a toss-up between how
long does an activity take
how ad intensive is it and am i likely
to get enough of the rules and are you
running with the same class because
ultimately you need to
try and stick with the same class to get
as many laurels as you can so just a few
things to bear in mind if you're jumping
in anyway
people the same classes get those builds
and elemental wells might as well make
the most of those
uh yeah man
i've been trying to figure out the best
way to do it and i can't really make it
out i feel like i thought master lost
sectors might be the play but actually
the more i think about it i feel like
actually
you get medals for each encounter in
raising dungeons so
am i just going to farm templar for
medals and then just get okay on for
completions just to get the contender
card done like is that what it's gonna
mean
i don't advocate that but that might be
the cheesiest way to do it to be honest
[Laughter]
yeah i think we're gonna have to see
between the bounties listed the medals
the contender cards what it's gonna take
to kind of get all those and how much of
a reset they're on and that type of
stuff so we'll just have to
kind of play it by your a little bit
what about you two gentlemen anything uh
just even strikes going does that sound
like something fun to bring you guys
back for looking to mix it up or could
not care at all trap hold on i gotta get
i gotta go travis's um snicker here
sorry i just strike scoring man i just
don't i don't understand strikes i
really don't want to swear in a
competitive playlist bro
like competitive mega sweaty and people
am i competing
against who am i to get the top 10 you
get an emblem bro like
oh my god
bro
i feel like
i feel like when i play strikes i'm
competing against my own patience is my
adversary really is is who i'm fighting
against i yeah i i just i've never
really gotten strikes doing the exact
same activity over and over again but i
will say i will say to their credit
strike scoring is at least like an
interesting end game
kind of way to mix it up that gives
if people were playing strikes every
week to try to get the highest score i
would kind of get it because i get like
speed running and being competitive and
trying to like improve your times and
that sort of stuff i don't really
understand the brain of a person like my
friend brian malkowitz who that's all he
does is he just jumps into the strike
playlist and i'm like who are you like i
don't know
what are you doing like that's what you
do you just log on to destiny and you
just hop in the strike playlist that to
me the mindset that does that is like
is is you know on the spectrum somewhere
i i don't know what part of it but
they're they're uh they're not all there
but uh yeah i guess i guess the thing
i've the thing i've not really enjoyed
about guardian games so far is that they
don't really add anything they're just
like hey do the same activities you've
already done but this time do it for the
glory of your class and you know the
first year i did it i did it a ton
because i was like yeah titan's rule we
got to win this but then after we won i
sort of was just like the second year i
was like i'm sick of this i don't want
to do it again um so i would love it if
they gave some specific unique activity
or reason to log on and do something so
if if strike playlist and scoring is is
on the menu
i'll give it a try man i'm you know
whatever i'm not usually in for strikes
but it is something different so i'm not
gonna knock it until i try it um but
yeah just generally speaking anytime
they say hey travis you're gonna do
strikes i'm like dude
please please don't make me i don't
wanna i don't want to
so how about you cog i was like
definitely definitely on the other side
well d1
i don't know what it is i understand
your your
question of it um
i don't know what it is it's just a
visual incentive it's just like i don't
know just something that just makes my
mind go ooh psychological triggers of
joy
yeah like it was just i remember when
they added it and at first i kind of had
to make myself like ah what's this like
what's why you don't say that kind of
thing but then as you play strikes and i
think what it is i think strikes is kind
of like the chill activity
with your friends like not to name drop
but like there are a lot of um
executives or gaming developers i know
they want to play that do play destiny
right and that's all they want to do
like they just want to get in there
put some strikes and just just chill out
and i think it's just more of a you know
i'm playing with my friends yeah in this
non-stressful situation
chill situation you you'll be surprised
like there's a lot of people that do
that and i know there are just like 60
percent of the players right yeah
it's for us
after a while it's like all right enough
right but for something they will live
in that playlist and and they loved when
you know the strike scoring was there
and they love now that bungie does the
the longer you stay in it the more
chance you get
or whatever yeah you know what i'm
saying kind of thing so yeah it's just
like a little fun little thing for me
and and i just like the incentive and
then you know you talk a little smack i
think for me it's always destiny there's
a game within the game
and the game within the game for me
is the the either the post
red encounter report when you look at
everybody dps and who ain't doing what
they supposed to be how many people did
you kill why did i have to carry you
through the strike like what are you
doing get off your butt it's the mini
game of destiny on the pve side that
people at the end of like from our
carriage look at all i had 254 look at
all the streaks i had about it
you're the type of person who wants like
a little
like post boss kill
to show dps numbers not just on death
you want to see it on kill because
you're like yeah we got through that but
thanks to me
you want those bragging rights
you can tell he does that now you can
tell things are striking like yo i got
200 kills i got
you know i got like 100 precision kills
and then like i created the most orbs i
carried these guys man
and i had to be revived 80 times because
my gun ass was too far in front
of the game within the game you got to
talk a little smack and to me there's
nothing like again i know we're talking
strikes but there's nothing more fun
like dj's in the chat a lot of back for
dead forte to me there's a secret part
of me that loves when we lose a razor
counter can't take a rock or whatever
and it's just a silence
and the
the the death screen comes up yeah
and you look at the dps you see
bro what was you do what are you using
he's just calling people out and raised
me like all right hold on i'm going to
inspect you nobody move we've got to do
an inspection and we've got to do an
intervention right now yes it's great my
excuses i'm always the divinity dad
if you're the divinity guy you're good
that's my excuse
like fifth i've got questions oh yeah
yeah if my divinity out is you we gotta
we gotta talk yeah that's fair but yeah
sometimes you learn
not to keep going with this but
sometimes you learn i think it was um
what was it when focusing lens came out
and i was looking at somebody's dps i'm
like how are you doing all like they
were lapping me you know what i'm saying
and i was like what are you you had i
learned about focusing less yo they
going crazy no dj had the best one he's
like travis are you using guns with ammo
that is
after we lost i talked to somebody and i
was like hey you know the this game has
guns
you can point them at things and shoot
them and the guy was just like pissed
i think it'll be fun i'll be curious to
see if there is because there used to be
like rainbow get kills with all
different types of damage or all weapons
or i'll be curious what the strategies
are that people come up with because you
know people are going to be like all
right here's how you run a strike
best things run and parent everybody's
running that's the stuff i'll be kind of
curious to see so more than anything and
the main reason is
you've actually got a reason to be
competitive for travis sake um but
there's going to be a leaderboard so the
top 10
at the end of the event so you'll take
your top for
week 1 week 2 and we three and combine
all those scores together and the top 10
of all guardians are going to get an
emblem and while the little square one
is just guardian games all the little
banner flags actually looks really cool
on the big wide one because they changed
this one oh good we got some uh fun
people coming in chat there we go yep
uh but we've also got a new weapon which
i'm assuming is gonna be coming from
what it describes the competitive the
rewards and those things we've got a new
weapon for this one air apparent still
gonna be there i will scream it out now
please make sure
get air apparent get the catalyst do it
the discarding games because if there's
ever been a time to have a machine gun
season 17 is going to be it so do not
sleep on air apparent please get that
weapon
that being said we're also getting a new
smg it's called the title and it will be
a hockey void smg aggressive frame and
it's got a unique origin perk classy
contender which grants class ability
energy on final blows with this weapon
it's got a lot of perks but it sounds
like we're going to be able to
masterwork it get double perks in the
third and fourth column again i'm
guessing the high levels the high scores
all tie into that
um
people have been talking about with the
meta shift literally last week saying
shotguns are being rained in a little
bit fusions are being rained in a little
bit i've heard some of the pvp people
going
sidearms smgs are going to have some
potential in that alternative
yeah smg's so this is not one to sleep
on aggressive frames are going to be
your 750s kind of like ikelos
um extraordinary rendition those type of
style
so depending on if you like if you can
manage the stability the range usually
is going to be decent on it
but overall
it's not recall on pc there's no
stupidity
that's why again for us like i'm good
grab grab all the range i can get on
some of these things
but in theory though like there's people
who are leaning so heavily into class
abilities lately with the warlock rifts
and all the stuff you guys can do there
lori helm and all our barricades for
titans we've been having a lot of fun
dodges and invisibility the class
ability seems like it does have more
potential than i would say it has in
quite a while especially with void 3.0
so just getting specifically
classibility unlike wellspring that
spreads it but if you focus on a class
ability and you really are good with an
smg i'm sure you could lean into that
class ability even more am i crazy or do
you guys think that actually has any
potential
i might actually jump in and agree with
new red i do feel it's a little gimmicky
but it depends on how substantial the
gain is if it's like
you know
i feel demolition this is okay you know
i don't want to actually i'm not upset
or what wait a little bit
tell me if you agree with this job how
do you feel about wellsprings games on
the on the kills i always feel like it's
low so i don't know i just look at it
like i just hope it's
not such a small percentage based on the
fact that i know
the last update they were very
conscientious about ability up time and
usage and and then we got point three
point i think we have four people
yeah
i didn't know yeah
bolts right so it's like um
and i mean the wellspring is low but
then that's because it's split across
three abilities so
that kind of makes sense um
the mobility cooldowns tend to all the
class ability cooldowns tend to be less
than grenade anyway so
i would probably say that it's going to
be lower than
the demolitionist in that sense but more
than well spring it's going to be like
this middle ground i would say might
even
dust off the promethean spur for the
warlock and just put rifts absolutely
everywhere
um
it could be good though avoid smg but um
is it enough
probably for a free event probably is i
don't mean there's not much else i
expected the um you get your first one
from the
uh quest and pick it up from eva levante
then i guess additional drops dropped
from
medals that you hand in at the
uh podium in the town and that's this
is the secret inside scoop information
you got right here
this is the he's like oh i know how to
get this quest do you have all the steps
for the quest already pre uh there's one
quest that's got 18 steps that runs for
three weeks that's that runs through the
whole course of the event there's
multiple quests there's two
there's an exotic quest for air apparent
but it's only like a two-part quest easy
yeah and then there's a separate one for
the catalyst which i assume you get
after
you've got the exotic whether you've got
it already or whether you're getting it
for the first time
there is a lot of quests there there is
a lot of steps but
um
the guardian games ones at least the
opening quest is pretty sure
that should give us our first that's
always the case it's about this is what
guardian games is it's the introductory
quest for new players which makes makes
sense
and this is how it works is how you get
loot this is what you need to chase sort
of thing so
it is what it is i mean like free events
i don't think they're going to evolve
too much over time it's a
it's time versus cost investment isn't
it from a bungee standpoint it's
primarily pushing eververse and how much
revenue that generates yeah and i mean
they won't say that but that's what free
events are so
um but i don't mind i mean i quite i
want to look like a badass like the the
armor looks awesome
so which armor
i want i want rankings i'm going to
start with travis jarv and cog i want to
know rank the
guardian games armor number one number
two number three
travis
okay let me let me pull him up again so
i can refresh him yeah
let's see we got
they're all pretty good
up real quick honestly i'm gonna i'm
gonna go with titan
i know that sounds biased but like
i don't know if it's maybe this titan is
so confident with their hands on their
hips like that
got that command but yeah i like that i
like that power stance but uh
it's it's actually a sleek titan armor
which yes we don't we don't see a whole
lot
um
it's showy but not too showy if you know
what i mean
um
hashtag hunters
and um yeah i don't know i like it i
think that's probably my favorite one
these are all pretty good though we'll
see if they actually what's your number
two what's your number two
number two
um
yeah i think i'm gonna go warlocks for
number two and then three for hunters
hunters are just a little
a little um
gaudy you know
a little gaudy to me oh i just thought
it was underwhelming anyway uh jerf
one two three
um i would say
uh warlock titan hunter personally
i'm not a big fan of the hunter helmet i
don't know really yeah it kind of looks
tight for a hunter but yeah yeah it's a
little robotic i'm going
i'm i love the wallet i don't know how i
feel about the helmet but overall i'm
biased yes warlock i actually like the
hunter
i actually like the hunter i i like the
the no accounting for taste i guess
i don't know why i like the showy i like
i'm jealous of hunter hoods i'm jealous
i think it's something it's cool and i
like the titan suit too it's not like
the titan's bad i i like it too it's a
unique take i don't know how i feel
about that loin cloth though
i don't know how i feel about it you
know what you know what it is i figured
out why i don't like the hunter helmet
tell me it looks like a sweeper bot
it does i think it looks like the
sweeper bot's head it do if you really
look here you go beyond the hood yeah
that's what i think of them
now the warlock helmets just fire along
with the big just like the way they have
the tone down the middle titan looks
pretty good and titan was close to me
the
um honestly the hunter wasn't it was
like
titan hunter or titan or warlock and
titan are like real close personally
like i like them both hunter like way
down here like i didn't think the hunter
was close to the other two personally
whatever reason
like you've got the bit you've got a lot
of the red you got almost like tron look
for the titan the warlock you've got
like the yellow down the middle i love
the shape of the helm for whatever
reason from the angle it's at maybe it's
gonna look weird and then the hunter
just looks like
gray hunter and i don't know why just
just not do it for me
interesting i think the hunter's quite
safe isn't it i feel like i've it looks
like a lot of other armor
the hunters with like the titan like
trav said it's actually quite a lean set
is that uh compared to like that's true
the rhino sets from leviathan you know
it's you don't yeah
chunky boys
quite
different in that aspect and it's nice
quite like it
and the wall like yeah
it's just whether they shade well
yeah they look good as they are
but
everyone wants to put their own spin on
them and uh
because cloth and actual
armor
okay differently so
if it's in the pudding we ain't got long
to wait so yeah yeah we'll see
uh but yeah there was a very interesting
little chart that came out so again
they're gonna try and balance out the
days the bonuses and the boost you get
for points because
hunters warlocks and
titans they had the numbers here on the
chart i think it is absolutely hilarious
on march 5th
there is a drop in hunters there's a
smidgely drop in titans and a large
boost in warlocks what happened on march
5th that everybody felt like they needed
their safe class to play
raid
that is the raid day and the next day
down
day one raiders bringing warlocks in
there
and then they turn around and they go
back to pvp
that that is 100 well of radiance i can
that's definitely the well as yeah they
quickly realized we don't need well
yeah yeah yeah that's one well in that
race yeah and then after that but yeah
it's very funny titans never get above
30.
warlock's sitting in that like you know
just under 35 and hunters never drop
under 35 and the titans are down here
we're holding down the minority thanks
guys yeah
hold it down bottom
no it's just slight uptick in hunters
when gm's launched as well
everyone got an invis
[Music]
getting their conquerors and stuff so
yep
like i wouldn't run anything than a
hunter in light blade for example oh god
yeah so um
watch and follow up trying to do that
thing solo is just
i don't think he ever got it done
i think he's like a leopard earlier bro
he was like got the boss down to like
five percent health he'd been in there
three hours
and he
he he gone messed up a little bit at the
end and uh
wiped after three hours
see okay like i saw
something and say this is gonna derail
us i don't know
uh he tweeted something to say he's like
do i need to do a video over like the
acute burn stuff is that like a
discussion we need to have
i know you've probably done gm's i
soloed arms dealer because it's you can
she's the boss but i still got to the
end of it
but then i was working on trying to solo
glassway and i got to the boss room and
i found a little like cheese nook that
you could go in because you can at least
get a second to breathe in there
um
but just that like
instant delete and i feel i used to solo
diet falls very frequently that was like
one of the things i love doing in d1 i
haven't done that as much and even less
so with this type of stuff
one titan seems to be the worst class to
do it on but that's a different story
but it is now with the acute burns if
they if like a double splash damage is
like near you you're toast and i wanted
to kind of get your thoughts on
just where you think gms are at if
you're i mean granted you made easy work
of master vows so they may not be a big
deal to you but i was curious what's
your thoughts on just kind of where
those acute burns on gm's do you like
him not like him or were you at on gm's
in general
i mean much like the master raids man
they just rely so much on champions to
keep burns aside like
honestly
especially with glassway my goodness
in there it's just absurd
12 overloads in that final or something
ridiculous or eight
one thing
right one thing we haven't talked about
which i was i think's bad change is the
fact that they took away
the revives from lucent hive like you
know when we first got
three revised for getting a loose in the
hive down i was like yeah it's a
guardian yeah yeah bonus bonus revives
and then they said yeah that was a bug
wow livid bro couldn't believe it i mean
it doesn't matter if you're trying to
say a little bit but like
i don't know man i feel like they are so
much better than champions and more
difficult because they they pop their
super throws like one shield at you
you're you're gonna
literally
true threat they're far more lethal
even like two two revised because you
have to kill it and then you have to
crush the ghost right yeah
position too
um
so yeah just quickly touching on that
while we're talking about gm's is
to me that's a
bad change also please don't i'm gonna
say it probably every time please don't
do overload auto rifle smg
it's awful overload's already annoying
enough i don't need to try and have to
hit it 12 times
like i was i've been sitting there
unloading in a gm with an entire clip
there goes the health just
so demoralizing and on the plus side we
probably have some of the hardest gm's
in rotation all in one season like
corrupted isn't as hard as it used to be
after some of the changes they made the
cydia and stuff like that so
moving forward
you'd like to think but then that is a
cute burn their way of like actually
just turning the dial up a little bit to
make them more challenging later down
the line they might feel bad now
for things like
like blade
uh and birthplace of the vial i didn't
feel was too bad we just completely
burst damaged the boss and then just got
teleported away and didn't have to deal
with ads like that seemed like the
easiest way to do it and then we just
wait by the portal to get our supers
back
jump through and then just under crash
him like three times and then go back
um that makes sense
there's no
when you don't have time to react to
anything
travel no like we can get cheesy
loadouts in crucible where someone's
just one banging you with ariana's vow
and you don't have the time to react it
doesn't it
doesn't feel fun the fun fact is gone
because you can't react or counter it in
a way if if you don't get the you know
if you don't see it first
and from a pve perspective when you just
get in complete sometimes you don't even
see it it just comes out of nowhere and
then you get like this
replay or some silhouette of something
that killed you like that's behind three
walls it's like where did that come from
then and it's like
yeah it doesn't feel
it takes the fun factor out of it a
little bit
i mean fun in gm's is probably
pushing it a little bit because it is
more of the challenge rather than the
fun element um
but
yeah i'm not a massive fan because
there's not a great way for us to
counteract that even with mods on armor
like it doesn't do enough no
yeah the fact that you can just as you
said like the idea of
i don't mind something difficult
to a level like you know if you get out
of position you get hit a couple times
your health's gonna be low but you get a
second to maybe react getting to cover
at all but if you know if a minotaur
walks around the corner it's like bam
bam i'm like
and you're done your entire done is and
run his wife and especially on gm's
depending on how patient you are
depending on how many you're running
with you know it's gonna be 20 minutes
or if you're going solo it's like an
hour to get back to the same point just
to try it again it's frustrating so shut
up
just teleport won't they i'll just
teleport teleport
intentionally and unintentionally i mean
birthplace of the valve is the worst
you've got an unstoppable there on your
left and then
suddenly he's like 30 meters on your
right
and everyone if you run it regularly
people know that like wait a second he's
just going to glitch over there
oh yeah
should be a thing yeah on the glassway
the the moving because i spent way too
much time going through that by myself
and it was
the middle the sniper boss the sniper
like boss guy in like the third section
as you're working through kind of the
cavern
the way he would like jump off the lower
tier down into the abyss but then warp
up to the other side
yeah i was just like this is not right
movement this is so messed up
shout out real quick to
attack
tactics i think maybe or yeah something
like that for the five dollar super chat
sorry i mispronounced your name but
thank you for the five dollar super chat
in the sport appreciate it
um yeah i just
wanted to kind of get your take on those
because i've been trying to actually see
i'm not gonna solo light blade i don't
even know if i'm gonna get a light blade
done if i get close to doing some other
gm's i might have to
see about your help on a couple but just
the feeling of the acute the cap on it
and stuff it's just
even contest mode in the raid does not
feel as just instant dead as i think the
acute burn in gm's do it's
it's at the point of unfun to me
uh i did want to ask you on a separate
thing though are you part of the
guardian games cup are you in this thing
you can't say okay we'll just move on
basically what's happening is the
guardian
guardian games cup is going to be 42
teams across 14 territories
uh dunking out to see why titans are
best i do appreciate that line lay on
this jaw's face says it all um
sorry for the direction
uh but apparently it sounds like you
guys can tell me if i'm reading this
wrong just from the hosts because i'm
gonna let our guest be quiet for a
second it seems like there's gonna be
teams of guardians
like basically competing to kind of just
be the best team over the course of the
event it sounds like
uh back from the dead please don't say
that again that's awful
[Laughter]
i mean it's not an inaccurate
description
did you guys read this as basically i
know they say in real life but it's
basically real life guardians as a
three-person fire team trying to be like
the best during the course of the games
do you guys think this is just like them
trying to get the highest scoring
multiple events
what do you guys think i'm not asking
jarv because i'm trying not to
try not to let him uh trying to let him
maintain some
what i will say and which is what
they've said is that it's an opportunity
to raise money for a great cause there
it is uh regardless of the objectives
involved so
whether you're part of it or whether
you're not everyone can engage with it
in some way um
so
yeah any streamer coming near you
whether it be here or elsewhere then
definitely uh you know if you've got any
spare funds then they will go to direct
relief it's a fantastic cause so
got it trav's got a question i was i was
gonna ask how it is raising money like
what oh yeah are they asking for
donations but it's it's streamers are
giving the the profits from their
i think it's just donations
if it's direct relief it'll be through
the direct relief links so um it'll go
straight so it won't go to
anyone that's participating in it
whether there be
part of the team um so it will go
directly to direct relief and
we are the teams are merely the face um
to it to help to to engage the community
with the event i guess at that point
yeah the there are some donation prizes
could be random if you do up to a
certain level not sure yet they'll
probably get a little more detail next
week once it starts uh for the donation
prizes one of them is going to be a
piece of artwork from fyrian art if you
guys haven't seen his art it's always
fire beast and then the winning team
gets a custom digital piece by gamma
trap who he had on the show a while ago
homie we got a good game
with it for him too
amazing artists both of those if you
guys haven't seen him please check both
of those out credible artists there's so
many in the community but yeah those are
two legit ones for sure that i'm aware
of so
um season 17 got a little preview the
to not very i guess a huge surprise the
pursuit weapon is a machine gun
it looks very similar to the swarm so it
might be one of the slower firing ones
as you were saying cog could fit in that
style um
feels like it's going to be that way
you're going to have your different
skins for crucible gambit vanguard
uh the playlist of weapons we're getting
a crucible fusion rifle called riptide
we're going to get a gambit shotgun
called deadweight which there's a lot of
jokes in that one i'm sure but i just
can't come up with all of them right now
and then vanguard we get the strident
whistle bow i love bows so please give
me a solar bow because we are in dire
need of a solar legendary
um so hopefully the vanguard one is
solar or craftable or all of the above
nightfall drops we got a couple uh
throwbacks we got the horror's least
pulse rifle kind of like your darkest
before it is an arc rapid fire frame and
then the dfa i have not heard that in
years man throwback
that is a kinetic 140 hand cannon i
don't even remember the name of the
strike that was in
i never got it yeah probability three
probabilities yes three of probabilities
here those will become the best
grandmaster nightfall
ever oh i hear that strike oh mate yeah
that's that was that's probably worse
than light blade hold on give me refresh
me that's the big football boss with the
three-phase room for three rooms
oh no it was the other one what was the
other one called that was on mercury
the one you're talking about is garden
themselves garden uh
garden world
dawn road that's the worst one i've
heard
yeah
which one what's what is that what's the
boss at the end that's the eyeball
psychological eyeball with the rotating
and yeah
yeah that was rough yeah yeah i remember
that it was rough
i remember people would sit up in that
one little nook and just sit there and
plank away for forever just to try and
like hope to not die and you'd have two
people dead on the floor somewhere and
the guy just hoping to get shots off
somewhere yeah garden world void burn
still gives you yeah it's just awful
yeah back is right uh but true
probabilities it's the one with the
cabal where you kind of like do the
little sparrow piece through and the
three phases for the boss room yes yes
yes yes so that's where that's going to
fix
yeah yep and the trials is going to have
a sidearm called forgiveness and then
the burden of guilt also another fusion
rifle messenger and shire's wrath will
be leaving
the season 17 pools so if you want those
get those now
now is your time
to make sure you guys get those and then
also i think jeremy's leaving as well
palindrome
yeah
uh and then also for like your standard
playlist weapons like crisis inverted
which i don't think anybody likes harold
c auto rifle from gambit the vanguard
shotgun fortissimo it's just kind of got
its special little perk nerfed um that's
the stuff so
you got a few weeks left before we
basically get into you know full speed
season 17 what i wanted to ask you guys
is i know guardian games is coming
that'll have some fun for a little bit
this season was about four weeks long
before season of the risen and then
we've had a little downtime and then it
was like more difficult stuff
where do you guys feel destiny is in a
state when
a lot of the developers have been like
yo bungie and next season they've been
talking about the narrative and they're
really excited about what's coming for
the narrative that's four weeks that
goes you gotta break before grand
masters but if you don't love grandma if
you don't love hard content especially
some do some don't where do you guys
feel is that when destiny is now
post-season
if the seasons are gonna stay these four
weeks
so you go through the four weeks which
you know we've had talks of maybe the
shorter season is good so that
activities don't get repetitive yeah
it's like you only do it four weeks and
then you know feels like it's not
overstayed it's welcome
where do you guys think because this is
a question from earlier but where do you
guys think destiny is in a state is it a
state where
i don't know anybody want to take it i
just wanted to see these in-between
moments of like you know where are you
at in week six week eight week ten
before we get the new season where do
you feel destiny's at in those states
not like brand new season but
late season
yeah i mean i i think i've spoken a lot
on how i love it i i think you know i i
value my time i don't like repeating the
same activities over and over again and
i also think it sort of belabors the
point if your story takes like 12 weeks
to tell and it's just like okay
when are we gonna get to that thing like
let's just let's just do it so um i like
i thought that this was one of the
stronger seasons in terms of story and
then the cool thing about
about it being over quickly was there
was no pressure i didn't have to log on
every week or i would miss a week and be
behind on the story it was sort of like
all right i'll log on when they got iron
banner trials or something that i want
to play and uh when i don't want to play
it i won't play it and i just felt like
the uh the
lack of anxiety or the fomo that kind of
sometimes gestates within a destiny
player is uh is good to not have a round
because i can play destiny when i want
to and and not play it when i don't it's
been good man i got i got the uh the
raid exotic this week oh
disciple nice nice so yeah i mean i'm
i've you know i'm getting used today
one of the more convoluted weapons i've
ever seen when you try and even read the
description you're like i don't even
know what i just read can i get a
physics degree to try and understand
what i just read like yeah
i really hope they give that somebody
actually meant something about that as
well i cannot remember who said it in
chat so if it's one of you guys who are
in there now i apologize
that exotic is so void 3.0 specific
it feels like it should have been season
of the risen type exotic or something
else and then like lubrae's ruin
should have potentially been exotic
a good exotic because that's literally
the boss's weapon and then we get this
random void 3.0 so it's just somebody
mentioned that i was like that is 100
yeah i agree with that one but yeah i
got the exotic a few weeks i haven't
even fired the thing yet because i know
it's just a matter
it is an absolute mess see i got a i got
the worst raid weapon early
speaking of which there you go finally
sorry again
no i was i was just saying there you go
z he finally got that weapon oh yeah see
that's your rng for the vex there you go
i'm sorry i was it's too soon it was
just
the pain you can see i'm sorry i was a
baby too soon but oh yeah like i i
forgot to mention as far as the buffs
from the um
eyes of tomorrow i was thinking about
traveling this
that like got a nice little substantial
chunk man because 30 on yeah because or
30 on bosses or something like that so
maybe it'll be worth champions maybe i
can't remember what it was champ yeah
get get a job that's because i think era
made a video on it i think i made one as
well but like
it did they sent less damage against
champions and bosses so
it should do what it should have done
to begin with which means it should be
good
and and to your point job the reason why
i'm excited to cut you the reason why
i'm very excited one the pain it took
for somebody to get it trav apologies um
oh god oh 80 runs 80 runs
no doubt yeah
around there
in that same situation that for whatever
reason the rng was definitely busted
with that one but for me what kind of
because it was so hard to get there when
i finally got it and i'm not gonna lie
drop like when
gally came out
i'm like i'm never gonna use
you know what i'm saying like i'm never
gonna use it because i'm like
so now it gives me hope because i always
feel raid
exclusive exotics should have that kick
like tara but should be dominant you
know vex should be somewhat dominant and
um yeah oh you think grades should have
something that's worth going don't bless
the outlets
1k voices no
i still haven't
i haven't got 1k yeah dj's in there he
probably wants to run it right after we
do this yes i i don't have a guy it it
is i was happy about that so i just want
to talk about right now all right so the
exotic i'm missing is that helmet e i
got to get you to tell me the next time
the lost sector is helmets yes so i can
oh if i see it all i think i have a
schedule i'll send it to you so it's
fine oh yeah i think every season like i
end up forgetting about the last second
yeah exotic and then i just ask you to
like text me when it happens i was like
oh my god i'm gonna send you a schedule
after this just remind me to send you a
schedule and then you can put reminders
on your calendar so i don't have to deal
yeah but no i think you should i like
this premium service
you can offer it to all your followers
on youtube and twitter like just here is
calendar you schedule
here i need your direct phone number so
you get mine when i text you there's
nothing wrong with this
situation at all i i love our
relationship i think it's great and it's
one directional most important
totally beneficial to chat absolutely
yeah i'm crushing it out here
he's so stupid
he's questioning anyway
yeah seasons
i like it i'm fine i'm good you know you
get to catch up you get to break away i
think
i think i wanted to talk more about not
directly what you wanted to talk about
but kind of more about i wanted to kind
of pivot
um to
how i envisioned next season yeah i
think
obviously they're excited about the
narrative they're excited bungie
tweeting from the mountaintops i get it
i'm more excited about the combination
of another 3.0
and a dungeon
that's a that's a lot of me and a
multiplayer map and some maps
wait i'm sorry
did you say the words crucible map and
destiny 2 in the same sentence
yes because
this is where being traveled realign and
i have to go against jarvan one thing
which is
as as as great as which queen is and we
we love it
narrative storytelling at its absolute
finest witch queen is pinnacle rape for
the most part solid
but those are the modes
you know namely pvp so just to see a
little
nurture a little love a little care
towards it because i still feel as a
whole
um that destiny still needs to work on
the other things they're great in pve
right now they're fantastic they're
killing it but we still got to do the
the the pvp specifically specifically
the crucible stuff and all that so at
least now we're starting to you know get
a little thin here a little map here a
little you know just slowly you know
build that thing back up please that's
what's really work because i love pvp
so from what i've heard i feel like
they're building a ritual
activities team
bungie to focus on the ritual activities
is it would it be ritually in the pvp i
mean pvp's got a little bit next season
one new map
hey a babysitter
trials debt weapons there's little bits
there i mean it's not pvp focused like
the season clearly but um
i don't think we'll ever get that in
destiny i feel like that's really true
we still have a gambit focus season
right so um
we're gonna go down that road again um
yeah be nice it'd be nice i mean a new
crucible map is you know jokes aside
it's way
long overdue
uh and even just having some form of
uh
way of
just mo
map voting dude just yeah i've been
hearing that i want to play
like not exist crash
voting but that'd be a little different
you're right
uh it's
going to be nice just from a quality of
life
standpoint
maybe just add the you know competitive
and a social playlist that has all the
game modes in it so that we can
sympathize with other modes that never
get played i don't know well and it will
help with the player base right because
if you've got uh more players the games
will be
more enjoyable they'll be less and then
create ranks with rewards that you know
see
every season
imagine not
implementing the rank system from like
the last fps you made into your most
recent one or a similar creators
and they haven't done it for eight years
yeah yes it's a big opportunity i would
say that at this point but
it's nice to see some little auditions
for season 17 for crucible at least it'd
be interesting to see how they like you
said uh with the sailor 3.0
it's going to be a bit of a mess but you
know
like sun spots and a throwing hammer and
just absolute chaos and
yeah
sunspots behind a void barricade with an
overshield i can't think of anything
better bro
go ahead a quick question sorry um do
you think like how they did with void
3.0 where they like they kind of made us
lean into also utilizing it in
conjunction with void elemental weapons
do you think they will do the same and
like we will be pulling out a lot of
these solar weapons energy slots to
synergize in conjunction with an
artifact or you think they may not it
just may just be the actual subclass and
that's it
i think they'll lean into it because
they want i think every subclass
deserves its moment in the sun like no
pun intended um
it's this moment to shine right so
once you get all three at 3.0 then i
think you'll you'll create a bit more of
a balance and they could probably
lean into them generally um
but yeah i feel like it makes sense to
focus on it in some way so
if you haven't got good solar weapons
now
you've got a couple of weeks to get them
um
yeah it makes absolute sense it's going
to be burning and healing for
solar so yeah i've been wondering what
the verbs are going to because yeah
those are the two obvious ones like
burning
healing
but i mean they did like volatile
suppression they did so many more than i
thought for void i can't ever seem to
come up with six that
all make sense for solar yet i can't
quite get there
yeah mean because like volatile won't
exist anymore but they could do like
like
explosions of some kind yeah that makes
sense they could do something along
those lines explosions
um
like this season we're taking void 3.0
and overlapping that with elemental
wells like this is what i talked about
earlier with like yeah
all mine cells could actually be
triggering off multiple explosions and
you can just create a chain reaction
solar also continues right
like yeah void is overshield solar heals
that's kind of uh because
interestingly what i found out today
thanks to clan mate is that like the
suppression on
war mine cells doesn't actually engage
with any of the suppressive mods
season yeah for some reason
they're completely
separate from each other
they
it makes you think that actually some of
the solo elements
some of them may or may not work next
season so it would be interesting to see
yeah what doesn't doesn't i'm gonna have
to see how rage of the war mind
plays in as well with
that i might
interesting
with seasons just quickly going back to
that um i'm sort of along the lines of
trav a little bit i feel like actually
having
a little bit of a breather in the season
to feel like you can play destiny when
you want to play destiny not because you
feel that you need to
and
it's a it's a bit of a balance because
like you take the season like season of
the loss which was six months long
and it felt quite disjointed whilst it
was like 12 weeks to tell the story it
was like three months before we got the
conclusion and that just felt bad
because if you
join me whilst it gives a lot of people
time to catch up if you're
you don't have to engage with the game
regularly you'll notice the
the downtime um in between and they did
a fairly good job to keep people engaged
but narratively it sort of came to a
standstill i felt four weeks was a bit
short for a story but then
witch queen was the main story and if
history repeats itself the second season
of any given major expansion tends to be
the standout you just look at black
armory
dawn season of dawn
and chosen
goes in
there's some of the best seasons we've
seen
not just story-wise but just
what they had what they offered to the
game overall so
that might be part of why they're so
excited um season's generally about 15
weeks long though so
i feel like as long as the story's
probably not more than half of that it
gives us more than enough time to enjoy
and engage with the rest of what the
season's got to offer without feeling
like we're
oh mode
out which is something luke smith often
spoke about previously when he was game
director about trying to avoid so
yeah
i think like this season was the best it
could be without trying to
take the uh the spotlight off with
screen
yeah like the story beat which was
strong yeah yeah yeah yeah big time
really strong for like four weeks like
that little room in the helm
mm-hmm it was going down like one
cutscene but if the cutscene is worth it
oh yeah
and i i like i like the banter and
psyops i i like what was going on kaidel
and and uh what you call a saladin and
the crow like
it's still and then even afterwards now
you get kind of a little different post
dialogue
after this after the events of what has
happened with saladin which i like so
it's good character development so yeah
i agree
yeah i mean i'm with all of you guys
it's been nice i mean elden ring i
didn't get to start that until the
season kind of wrapped but as soon as
that wraps i'm like okay i kind of put a
pin in this
more of my time can be put into
something else while i still do you know
put up the youtube videos and stuff like
that
it is so nice to have that balance
because i think i've said it before
that's what keeps my relationship with
destiny healthy is my ability to step
away and play other things now
thankfully these are things i get to
choose to play as opposed to travis who
has to review bad things so i apologize
for travis's sake but he does get some
good ones occasionally but he's also
been put through the uh crap ringer
lately so hopefully your next one's like
i don't know a beast or something
but no it's like i'm getting to a point
where no
he knows what it is
i finished reviewing a game like a week
ago that was a
seven out of ten but yeah oh well it's
just not a two
i know i get i get i get the occasional
all right games yeah um but i mean yeah
i was like i want to play i've got like
two or three indies i want to play
horizon's kind of in the backlog for the
summer so that'll probably fall
when i'm surprised no horizon
basically it was well i mean it was
horizon destiny eldon ring it was
destiny then i'm playing elden ring and
then
i'm still playing el dorado
i
was
near you i was near towards the end and
then i was at millennia who's a tough
fight one of the hardest like if not the
hardest per se depending on what your
build is she got bugged with a recent
patch so i had basically just stepped
away she was impossible to kill because
even when she didn't hit you she would
heal she heard as a healing mechanic but
she would heal without even touching you
so i was like i'm gonna take a little
breather they fixed it recently they
told me so i gotta get back into that
and finish it because i've only got kind
of the final stretch to go i know it's
not a small stretch but i'm on the final
stretch so i do want to finish that and
then you know get back into the season
so
but that's the nice i i agree with you
guys the fact that the ending isn't good
we're not waiting for the final chapter
in the book thank you i was like i
appreciate that um whether it's four
weeks or six or however long of a story
they got to tell if they end the story
in successive weeks that's fine if you
want to do an epilogue a tease to go
into the next cool so i was like i like
they continue to learn and
like over the years i mean we don't have
a gambit focus season then you have
something like season of you know with
osiris and saint you're like this is
cool then on the other side
thank you angry no it's not that big um
then we've got
uh like chosen was like epic and you had
battlegrounds come in and just as you
guys have said the next season after an
expansion could be i didn't even think
about like the order of those but as
jarv said that that next season post
expansion is usually one of the best i
think the excitement is it's probably
time to get hyped and solar 3.0 and iron
banner rework all of it coming in the
same season yeah i forgot about that so
you've got iron banner slash yeah don uh
season of dawn the iron banner rework
coming in to
basically give that piece of pvp a
little bit more and another map is that
uh does that iron banner quest expire
this season yeah we're gonna have
another one next yeah yeah well
and in all your bounties your token
every token has got to go in this lesson
yeah i just i haven't played iron banner
yet so i'm i need to
next time it pops up i need to finish it
all apparently turn in all your tokens
it's the last time it comes up this
season so when it comes i think it's the
second to last week
so it's like the
i know it's not weak isn't it yeah i'm
trying to remember the day
procrastinating again
24th the
10th i think is when it will be may 10th
i think so the second week of guardian
games iron banner will be the last iron
banner of the season so turn in all of
your tokens i have like 2 000 of those
to turn in so i'll get a whole bunch of
crap
um but again if you get a good roll on a
solar machine gun save it you get a lot
of potential with that archons thunder
if you get a good one
i hope that new machine gun has chain
reaction but that's just me oh
that would be so much fun
i hope so too nice
subsistence shame reaction
yeah what happened the room exploded
moving on
uh anything else you guys got for this
one i know we actually managed to do
this under two hours which was kind of
surprising but
i mean we i i pulled us out of the
terrible terrible debate earlier
got us into the got us into the relative
content
and um but yeah and i mean honestly
guardian games well it may drag on like
you know burn through the stuff that's
important and see what you got but you
got you know three weeks left in the
season play as much or as little as kind
of you kind of like
pigeon thank you for coming in what's up
on the night shift
i've worked nights for seven years this
is like going back for me
yeah there's moments i worked so many
early
had a chat question from earlier i
thought i answered that one
new rad that was kind of what we were
talking about with regards to
kind of like ending out the seasons so
we didn't put a question to you guys
real quick so you know we got the uh the
dungeon
next season
yeah so
if where where what would you uh where
would you like to see that
because you know like grass was like
a bit of a labyrinth in the cosmodrome
like
look at the destinations that are in the
game now where would you
where would you put it
europa
i like that
we need to go back there yeah we're kind
of
beyond light
since it's you know passed and going
away
yeah i would like that yeah we haven't
done that we haven't done that i'm
trying to think because he got one on
dreaming city going on the moon
we've got prophecy which is that
literally still kind of somewhere in the
unknown so it was like where is that
just anywhere yeah and then we got side
of star horse
it's in star horses
um
grasp of course you said cosmodrome so
those are the four so this will be
number five
i was like world would be the other one
yeah it's like one of your favorite
world
somebody said why not throne world my
answer is because i've been at the
throne world for a lot recently so you
need a little bit of a
variety of suit all the swampy
you're going to trade out for all the
snowy
interestingly no one's no one's
mentioning nessus i thought about that
too but i was like some love but this is
it's been so long it feels like a very
arbitrary reason to go the only reason i
would wonder about something like nessus
is because
europa had like the new engine and
lighting done so it's going to stay in
the game for a while there's some of the
older destinations where i don't know if
they're going to like rework or sunset
so
they wouldn't put it in a destination
that would be older but if nessus is
still one of the biggest planets
um it's still got potential to stay
around
okay yeah give me a dungeon and pyramid
ship sold i'm done if it's there that
that'd be awesome
seventh dreadnought would be pretty sick
oh yeah
dj wants to join that fidget said the
ascendant played on the third throne
[Laughter]
yeah
i thought would be interesting like this
would be cool who do you guys think the
enemies because we've had
fallen taken
taken unfortunately um and then hive so
who do you guys think would be what you
got scorn left and vex
depending on where they go
it's time for the vex to come back out
maybe a vex
dungeon
please yeah yeah i'm okay i'm okay
without squirting yeah we haven't gotten
to wait for teleporting for 4500. we
haven't had have we got a vic's dungeon
am i just like
move brain for a second no there's only
four and two or yeah two are taken then
you've got cosmodrome with fallen and
hive for a pit of heresy yeah you've
only got four so no
2.0 oh god oh god he didn't actually die
imagine and we have to get him in the
dungeon i want 10x i want tanex to be
the boss and i want uh varex to scream
at 300 volume when he shows up i want
that too
actually the boss is aramis because she
got thawed
oh
there you go that was a rumor as well
actually wasn't it for next season
unthaw the thought that's what i said i
must do it
miss uh gets unthawed
next season that was a rumor yeah that'd
be
i'll be i thought about yeah i'd be
surprised they did it
that we're messing around with your
souls abilities and we accidentally melt
her yeah we're too strong with the fire
how strong are you too strong
uh
harim is longer that's a
that's a good uh good suggestion jar
yeah honestly i love dungeons so i'm
just like can't wait to get my hands on
the new one they're always my favorite i
really like dungeons
oh yeah this is nice and dragon not just
in destiny
so about the sponsorship so check out
advance
yeah i will say those of you guys who
enjoy advanced gg check us all out
tomorrow stay tuned good things coming
um
that's about all i got though
um you guys got anything else you want
to ask jarv well we got the celebrity
guest star here the
youtube rock star mr jarvinius
the sensation looks a man so what's the
job man proud eva probably i see the
grind i see the content is consistent
he's a warlock he's cool
he's got the perfect package man like
come on uk in the building absolute man
it's always good to to see what you're
doing and catch up glad you was able to
come through you know what i mean and uh
what other exciting projects you have
going on sir what else is going on with
you
it's
it's really uh
i've just been planning a lot for next
season really it sounds boring but yeah
it's like literally getting my ducks in
the line i think
you either fail to prepare or prepare to
fail right so
this is that consistency is all part of
the planning really um so yeah that's
really where i'm at
no
major bombshells in that sense uh
personally though like
like
it's
all the success that we've had over the
last two or three years is like put us
in a position to actually be out of
finally
get someone that we can actually call
their own actually buy our own place
hopefully that's the next year or so
like
so
it's mad because like you work a nine
till five and you're in a bit of a rat
racing and they've you know it feels
like you're living to paycheck to
paycheck it's quite wild and then it's
like oh never you know you can never
really put that money to one side to
actually make that step but
yeah this has put me in a completely
unique position that i'm
immensely grateful for and uh
potentially yeah
and you know a life-changing a major
life-changing event could occur as a
result so
yeah like personally that's where i'm at
and that's where like the headspace is
at my
my work standpoint is about being
consistent to make that a reality i
guess and it just goes to show if you
put your mind to anything and you work
harder if you're good at something
um and you enjoy doing it then you you
tend to get into a position to try and
get rewarded for it and uh
never yeah just put yeah
anything
everyone's good at something they just
don't know it yet i mean i've tried it
all
skills
crucible than i am so that that's a fact
for sure there you go maybe very good i
congratulate good good stuff man love
love to see it
love to see it
well as we wrap up jarv this is your
time to tell people who made it to the
end of the episode i really need to
start doing this in the beginning i saw
that on another podcast where i'm like
hey in the beginning where to find you
like your quick intro drop right there
at the beginning um where can people
find you what can they expect from you i
said half of it in the intro but tell
them what to expect from you um i know
it but they may not so you're the floor
is yours sir
uh you can expect
uh this week in destiny every week uh
because destiny resets every week so
that's always fun so you can get to know
what you need to know before you need to
know it which is always great so that's
an absolute given and obviously the
weekly research is a an absolute must as
well so
consistent cadence of content is what
you can expect from me and that is
there's no liberation stop that yeah man
so that's uh that's where we're at um
in terms of where you can find me
everywhere at jar venus pretty much
everyone calls me jarv even my mom at
one point that was really awkward but
anyway
i'm sorry
paycheck hit
[Laughter]
barely even hear it nowadays but it's
all good uh yeah that's where you can
find me and that's what you can expect
that's hilarious it sounds so funny for
you to say you've been told off that
sounds so
it's so brilliant i love it yeah so
british but also so like you've been
told off like that sounds worse than
being cussed out in the states like yeah
totally told off is like no that's they
just destroyed you with words somehow
that just cracks me up uh travis what do
you got on the horizon something you
can't talk about and anything you can
talk about
um i think i can talk about most of the
stuff i'm i've worked on so yeah i've
got a couple reviews coming out soon uh
content you can find at ign.com um my
latest review i think
okay i feel like i played this game like
a month ago but uh the next review i i
have that's going live is of trek to
young samurai uh type game um that's
going live on may 5th
uh which still is like super far away
yeah i played that game so long ago um
and then uh yeah i've got some other
stuff on the pipe but you can
you can find me uh on twitter at ty guy
travis you can watch all my reviews
previews and other stuff on ign.com and
uh on sundays i fight with a lawyer uh
for some reason on a show
yeah
well we we rarely see eye to eye but we
uh we love each other uh so um you can't
you can watch me uh watch me do that on
uh on sundays at uh 8 a.m pacific um if
you want to wake up early and hang out
with me um and yeah that's it love love
being here love fighting with cog love
you mister cuffs with my boy yeah
i'm gonna be like the ref on the
sidelines when you two get into like a
ufc match over here so yeah but here's
the thing you're you're a biased ref
you're always on his side you're never
ever laughing on my side you're like
you're like a ref but instead of wearing
the stripes you've got like his team
jersey over here you're like sure that's
a drunk for sure
break it up guys okay
get that extra hidden
i'll let it slide go ahead
handsome some brass knuckles
that was good that was good
what about you man what do you got
upcoming
look a lot of packs coverage um please
check it out we really hit a lot of
games there the double a space triple a
space some phenomenal games evil west go
check that out track the yomi which um
travis is about to review we got you
know a lot of good stuff coming in in
the gaming space also defining duke
where maddie plays maddie came up the
packs that was cool we got to hang out
so dope man i love maddie man he's
hilarious and um yeah i a little podcast
you already know every sunday's the
lord's day more gas more fun than
cooking and honestly i'm getting excited
about gcx i've been planning been doing
a lot of stuff going on there xbox
decides to do something to annoy me
so i'm gonna have to pivot because the
tickets were already purchased and
flights
already made
so um so i mean you could just record
there right yes yeah i'm probably going
to do e3 work for ign from the hotel
from the hotel room yeah i i need to do
it together we might need to work
together all of us like literally and if
we could get a conference room or
something i'll be dope um need to find
out about the high-speed internet in the
leviathan rosen shingle creek i don't
think they've discovered high-speed
energy oh god fluidity they've got
high-speed alligators
i don't know what fire is let's go
to starbucks
wi-fi is that that new uh strain of meth
you're so disrespectful for
good to be back it's good to be back
like i
i really missed it because when i when i
came back and i read the notes i'm like
i missed all of this juicy 12 and you
know how i get with sandbox patches and
all that stuff so it's going to be back
and of course driving the building e
what is going on with you
uh well it sounds like i'm gonna be able
to finish elden rings i gotta do that in
the off time um same thing
trying to
see what i've got ready for guardian
games coming up get ready for season 17.
um
and then just watch the rocket ship of
jarv on the youtube world leave and
travel to the moon and mad respect man
no seriously i'm very thank you for
bringing us on to for coming on tonight
first off um but honestly like your hard
work and your success is awesome to
watch and i'm very very happy to see
that because
you've kicked a bunch of butt and you've
like had your head down grinded and it
is it's working so
happy happy for the success and happy to
see those life change changing events
coming your way because you've earned it
appreciate it man super kind
for me evontas everywhere twitch twitter
youtube you guys know where to find me
um yeah stay tuned for
either streams for me you guys know
where to follow but please
iron lords podcast lords of gaming.net
lordcognito find him travis please find
all of his things related to um youtube
and then the bitcasts where i know
they're going to be doing something i
might
i maybe maybe swinging by the cast we'll
find out maybe
maybe you're gonna be there yeah so
there's getting around she's moving
ain's reached out so i guess i gotta
figure it out so you might find me on
sunday chatting for a little quick uh
pop in
and then um please
go follow jarv everywhere just look up
that find the v and you guys will find
amazing content from a very very awesome
gentleman so
that is where we wrap up this episode so
thank you all very much for being here
chat you guys have been awesome again
thank you the hosts thank you to our
guest and for this episode it has been